public sénat en partenariat avec afp les
échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir madame la
ministre
et merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté cette
invitation de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et avec la fp
m'aider représenter ce soir par lucile
brio et paul aubry à bonsoir on sera
tous deux en matière d'innovation madame
la ministre puisque c'est également
votre responsabilité vous avez fait donc
sensation avec cette réforme de l'accès
à l'université qui a donc donné lieu et
qui donne encore nous allons en parler à
contestation dans quelques
établissements de moins en moins
nombreux d'ailleurs on peut le constater
ce soir vous répondrai au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions
injustement le déblocage par la police
des facs qui s'est poursuivie ce matin à
grenoble et montpellier at il eu raison
selon vous de ce mouvement étudiant
deuxième question est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de la mise en oeuvre de
parcours sub puisque les lycéens en
maintenant exprimer leurs voeux alors
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur dire nous
verrons cela tout à l'heure enfin
troisième question
l'université française peut-elle encore
tenir son rang face à la concurrence
mondiale on peut dire que les
classements internationaux ne sont pas
toujours flatteur pour notre pays
première question donc de cette émission
que va vous poser palau bria
[Musique]
les deux étages des facs qui s'est
poursuivie ce matin à grenoble et à
montpellier at il eu raison du mouvement
étudiant alors ce qui s'est produit ce
matin à grenoble à montpellier c'est de
nature différente
montpellier il n'y avait plus
d'étudiants et c'était simplement un
constat des dégâts qu'ils avaient qui
avait été engendrés ces dernières
semaines qui s'est produit sur sur
grenoble le président de l'université a
effectivement demandé à ce que un site
puisse être rendue aux étudiants et aux
enseignants de manière à ce que les
choses se déroulent normalement alors
une situation s'apprécie vraiment
université par université club allemand
quand même est-ce que vous estimez
effectivement que ces déblocages qui se
succèdent aura peut-être d'autres encore
marque la fin ont eu raison de ce
mouvement
non moi je crois que une fois de plus un
il faut distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer les endroits où un petit
nombre de personnes ont confisqué
l'université ont commis des violences
des dégâts etc et où le président
d'université estime qu'il n'est plus en
capacité parce que parfois il n'a plus
le même accès aux locaux d'assurer la
sécurité des personnes et des biens est
donc là évidemment eh bien ils demandent
à la police
une intervention et c'est à ce moment là
le rôle de la préfecture de juger de
l'opportunité de l'intervention
et puis il ya des endroits où c'est le
débat qui a lieu ça c'est normal dans
les universités et où il ya des
assemblées générales où toutes les
opinions peuvent s'exprimer
c'est une différence fondamentale avec
les assemblées générales dans lesquels
seuls quelques individus ont la parole
et les autres sont exclues et ne peuvent
parfois même pas entrer un point assez
précis aujourd'hui de la situation dans
les universités françaises
est ce que vous savez précisément
combien sur toute la france sont
aujourd'hui bloqués ce soir encore alors
on a trois universités qui sont qui sont
bloqués sur soixante dix ans vient sur
73 universités et
université en fait c'est plusieurs
facultés plusieurs sites à peu près 400
400 sites universitaires en france et il
y en a sept qui sont perturbées alors il
ya des blocages à lyon par exemple
encore qu'elle vous quels sont les les
universités concernées
alors il y à un bâtiment à à metz un
autre un an signe de mémoire bloquées à
rennes ii actuellement
voilà mes pairs également voté le
blocage jusqu'au 2 mai si je ne m'abuse
seulement on a vu que tolbiac avaient
été évacués dans les conditions qu'on
connaît par les crs
au milieu de la nuit la semaine dernière
et est ce que la même chose au à se
produire à nanterre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous signez un petit peu
la fin de la récré vous siffler la fin
de la récré ou dit bon voilà il ya eu le
temps du débat maintenant il faut que
les examens puissent se tenir
est ce que les forces de l'ordre doivent
procéder de la même manière à nanterre
cattle biac alors à nanterre le
président de l'université
un matin en découvrant une bande
d'individus cagoulés et armés de barres
de fer en train de rentrer par
effraction dans un bâtiment a
effectivement fait appel aux forces de
l'ordre parce qu'ils ne savaient pas ce
qu'ils étaient en train de se passer et
il y avait un réel danger
on n'est plus dans cette situation
actuellement actuellement il est en
train de discuter avec avec les
étudiants de manière à ce que les
examens puissent se tenir normalement au
cours du mois de mai il faut bien
comprendre que les étudiants qui
bloquent les universités actuellement
sont en train de pénaliser les étudiants
qui sont les plus fragiles
les étudiants qui sont que j'ai
travaillé pour payer leurs études les
étudiants boursiers ceux qui ont
absolument besoin d'avoir leur diplôme
pour candidater sur des masters donc la
tenue des examens
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important tous les présidents
d'université ils sont attachés et bien
sûr je ferai en sorte de les aider à ce
que les examens se tiennent dans leurs
locaux ou dans d'autres locaux mais la
semaine dernière on a beaucoup parlé du
blocage de tolbiac la semaine dernière
sept mille étudiants ont passé néanmoins
leurs examens la semaine dernière deux
mille étudiants ont passé leur examen à
montpellier les examens se sont déroulés
à l'est
ils sont en train de se dérouler dans
plusieurs sites universitaires pour
certains cette semaine vous aurez vous
vaincu ce mouvement de contestation
quand justement tout l'examen auront été
passés enfin aucune modalité on va en
parler aussi mais vous estimez que vous
aurez vaincu ce mouvement à ce moment là
moi je crois que c'est très important je
cherche pas à vaincre le mouvement je
cherche simplement à comprendre quelles
sont les causes d'inquiétude qui
s'exprime
lorsque ce sont de vraies inquiétudes de
manière à pouvoir expliquer quel est
l'objet de cette réforme je le rappelle
c'est d'abord une meilleure orientation
ensuite c'est qu'on ne tire plus au sort
les étudiants lorsqu'ils rentrent à
l'université et enfin ces données à
chaque étudiant ce dont il a besoin pour
réussir
et ça c'est quand même assez nouveau moi
j'ai longtemps enseigné en première
année par plaisir parce que pour moi
c'est un plaisir d'enseigner en première
année d'université et je sais très
exactement à quel point c'est difficile
pour les enseignants chercheurs de voir
les amphis se vider au cours des
semaines passées de blocage et aussi
beaucoup de dégâts aujourd'hui à combien
vous estimez ces dégâts sur l'ensemble
des facs qui ont été occupées alors les
estimations elles sont en cours le
toulouse notamment qui a fait l'objet
d'une énorme rénovation en 2016 la fac
que parmi divers cité jean jaurès pour
350 millions d'euros à priori à une
norme est donc là c'était le coût de la
rénovation
a priori il ya énormément de travaux
pénibles hiroshi alors sur toulouse j'ai
pas d'estimation précise le président de
l'université montpellier iii annonce à
peu près 300 mille euros de dégâts sur
les salles de serveurs l'université j'ai
choisi sur l'université de tolbiac les
devis sont en cours mais on parle aussi
de
deux à trois cents mille euros et qui
doit payer au final parce qu'à un moment
c'est des gars il va falloir que
quelqu'un les assume est-ce que vous
encourager les présidents d'université a
porté plainte
est-ce que c'est à ceux qui ont occupé
de finalement assumé le coût de ces
dégâts c'est à l'état de prendre en
charge
on fait comment alors j'ai pas les
inciter à quoi que ce soit mais
effectivement que certains présidents
d'université font faire des
constatations par la police
effectivement avec pour objectif
derrière de pouvoir porter plainte parce
que c'est important
maintenant comme je voulais dire lorsque
des individus ont été identifiés en
train de casser il était souvent
cagoulés la démonstration va être
difficile mais il n'empêche que c'est
important de savoir qui a commis ces
dégâts parce que effectivement c'est le
contribuable qui qui va payer l'argent
des universités c'est de l'argent public
et voilà pour financer les universités
et la difficulté c'est que évidemment
moi je ne souhaite pas que l'argent qui
a été investi notamment pour mieux
accueillir les étudiants soient utilisés
pour repeindre des amphis pour faire des
serveurs donc voilà c'est je serai à
côté des présidents pour trouver avec
les meilleures solutions qui ne pénalise
pas leur université
mais pas d'estimation du coût global
alors on va je pense qu'on dépassera le
million d'euros le million d'euros pour
l'ensemble du coup on en a on est déjà
quasiment 600 milles sur les doctrines
toulouse comme si vous avez vécu ce
week-end la rumeur d'un étudiant plongé
dans le coma après l'intervention des
forces policières à tolbiac est ce que
vous avez
réagit est ce que vous considérez que
ceux qui ont propagé cette rumeur
doivent s'excuser médias de de la france
insoumise l'unef également accréditer la
thèse de cet étudiant dans le coma j'ai
trouvé ça absolument abjecte
il n'ya pas eu d'étude encore non non
bien sûr que non je confirme qu'il ya eu
des finances comme à je trouve que c'est
abject je reprendrai volontiers les mots
de raphaël enthoven sur le sujet c'est
voilà je crois qu'il a dit que
l'étudiant blessés que l'on invente
c'est peut-être le mort que l'on
souhaite je trouve que c'est
incroyablement violent de faire ça je
trouve que c'est une voie là c'est pour
moi c'est inadmissible c'est
inqualifiable
je pense là aux gens qui ont le malheur
de perdre quelqu'un de jeune dans leur
entourage dans leur famille faire passer
ce type de rumeur effectivement ce nom
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on cherche
vraiment vous vous attendez peut-être
des excuses aujourd'hui certains
s'expliquer moi je j'attends tout au
moins que les personnes qui ont colporté
ces rumeurs effectivement reconnaissent
que ces rumeurs sont fausses
g j'ai noté effectivement sur quels
types de médias elle avait été propagée
par quel type de personne
le média le média qui qui a avait l'air
de se réjouir absolument de cette
nouvelle qui lui a permis de faire du
buzz
je trouve que c'est tout sauf du
journalisme
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce mouvement de
notre époque
plus globalement parce qu'on parle aussi
beaucoup de ces fakes news qui se
propage qu'on a du mal à endiguer qu'est
ce que ça dit de notre époque de ce
mouvement
sadi probablement que au moins pour
partie il y a une envie d'
instrumentaliser des choses et une envie
de se mettre en scène ya une envie de
théâtre il ya une envie de faire croire
que les quelques centaines d'étudiants
qui bloque représentent la majorité des
étudiants chaque fois qu'une
consultation électronique est fait
l'écrasante majorité des étudiants sont
contre le blocage souhaite passer
un examen c'est un peu la démocratie
confisquée
lorsqu'on organise des regroupements
dans lesquels on interdit l'accès à
certains étudiants parce qu'ils ne
partagent pas les idées lorsque l'on
tags des locaux de l'union des étudiants
juifs de france
lorsqu'on écrit sur les murs un bon flic
est un flic mort la semaine où on
célèbre le collen betram et on à
l'attentât de trèbes
voilà lorsqu'on est capable de faire ce
genre de choses c'est que on veut
instrumentaliser les universités on veut
instrumentaliser les étudiants et
l'université ne se laisse pas
instrumentaliser en tout cas moi j'en
suis convaincu en tant qu'universitaire
vous avez été heurté par certains
ateliers qui se sont tenues dans
certaines facs je prends rien ils ont
cogné en non-mixité union vaste et
raciste vous avez hélas certains mettent
en cause par exemple la présence des
indigènes de la république dans
l'organisation de ces manifestations
mais vous confirmer on est dans un
contexte qui n'a plus rien d'un contexte
universitaire c'est vraiment ça qu'il
faut comprendre tolbiac n'y avait plus
rien d'un contexte universitaire les
lieux où se tiennent ces d'ateliers
n'ont plus rien d'un contexte
universitaire et puis en tant que
professeur de génétique
je vous confirme qu'il n'ya qu'une race
humaine dans tous les cas l'intervention
des forces de police c'était le thème de
notre première question du sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité
est ce que vous êtes pour l'appel aux
forces de l'ordre pour empêcher le
blocage des universités 59% jeu 2 oui
38% donnant on n'est pas surpris par ce
résultat
moi je crois que la façon dont on pose
la question est compliquée à la fois
bien sûr qu' il faut empêcher blocage
dans les universités bien sûr que les
universités on vous l'avait rappelé
l'habitude d'accueillir du débat parfois
de la contestation
et c'est uniquement lorsque les
présidents d'université ne se sente cuir
en capacité d'assurer la sécurité sur
leur propre campus que les forces de la
vente intervienne et là c'est normal
parce que on n'est plus dans un contexte
université vous avez évoqué des tags
antisémites
est ce que vous vous auriez signé le
manifeste du parisien l'a publiée
dimanche sur le nouvel antisémitisme
dans notre pays alors en tant que
ministre je pense qu'il vaut mieux agir
que signer des pétitions
c'est ce qu'on a fait le 19 mars dernier
en annonçant le plan de lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme avec des
actions très précises qui qui ont d'ores
et déjà commencé et est mise en place
donc voilà je pense que c'est ça le rôle
du gouvernement polonais après si vous
me demandez si à titre individuel
j'aurais pu signer c'est depuis qu'il
sait faire cette pétition
je ne suis pas 100 % d'accord avec tout
ce qu'elle contient mais en tout cas
elle a le mérite de poser un vrai
problème est de poser un problème qui
est une réalité aujourd'hui on a encore
pu le constater ces derniers jours et
c'est un vrai sujet peut-être encore une
question sur les examens vous les avez
évoqué madame la ministre monsieur
qu'est ce que vous donnez comme garantie
aujourd'hui aux exams aux étudiants qui
vont passer leurs examens est ce que
tous vont pouvoir les passer dans de
bonnes conditions alors bon on parle
évidemment des blocages de sites
on parle aussi de
la grève qui se poursuit à la sncf il ya
des étudiants qui galèrent tous les
jours pour se rendre sur les lieux
d'examen
est ce qu'il ya des aménagements qui
sont envisageables dans quelle mesure
alors ça évidemment le principe c'est
que les examens auront lieu et que cette
année universitaire sont pas validés oui
ça c'est vraiment extrêmement important
mais il faut bien comprendre que c'est
c'est l'état qui certifie les diplômes
qui sont donnés dans les universités les
universités organisée de la main et à
certifier les diplômes il n'y aura pas
de diplôme certifié par l'état
si les examens n'ont pas eu lieu donc
c'est très important que ces examens
aient lieu parce qu'une fois de plus on
a les étudiants internationaux qui
doivent rejoindre leur université
d'origine avec leurs semestre validé on
a les étudiants qui travaillent pour
payer leurs études
et si leur diplôme n'est pas valide et
qui vont devoir recommencer on a les
étudiants boursiers qui doit avec les
éventuels perturbateurs on n'a pas joué
à cache-cache je vous le dit la semaine
dernière
7000 étudiants ont passé leurs examens
une fois de plus je crois qu'il faut
sept mille étudiants de tolbiac l'est
beaucoup plus sur la france entière
je crois qu'une fois de plus il faut
ramener les choses à la réalité il y à
certains sites sur lesquels il ya des
difficultés mais même sur ce site là les
examens sont en train de se tenir avec
un bâtiment bloqués et les examens dans
l'entité a des côtés alors que le mans
auront lieu vous avez eu l'occasion de
croiser aujourd'hui je crois valérie
pécresse
la présidente lr2
de retour ce matin voilà condorcet pour
l'inauguration d'un bâtiment et là il
était à votre poste c'est ce que c'est
que la contestation des réformes
elle vous soutient elle salue une
réforme courageuse ou c'est un soutien
important pour vous aujourd'hui mairie
de madame pécresse à la fois madame
pécresse comme madame sur asos on se
sont exprimés et ont dit toutes les deux
effectivement il y avait un problème
auquel personne ne s'était attaqué
frontalement jusqu'à maintenant qu'est
ce taux extrêmement faible de réussite
en première année et cette sélection par
l'échec en première année en moyenne
c'est insupportable insupportable pour
les étudiants insupportable pour les
enseignants les enseignants chercheurs
ça doit être insupportable pour toute la
société
et justement c'est pour ça que donc vous
avez mis sur les rails cette réforme
dont on va parler tout de suite avec la
deuxième question de l'épreuve de vérité
que 20 vous posez lucile bréau
[Musique]
alors madame la ministre est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite aujourd'hui de la mise
en oeuvre de parcours sup je rappelle
que un peu plus de 800 mille lycéens ont
exprimé leurs voeux est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes satisfaite de
la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
alors il faut il faut séparer parcours
subset une plateforme est étonnant elle
a extrêmement bien fonctionné jusqu'à
présent les les lycéens ont pu ont pu
faire leurs voeux ont pu finalement
exprimé pour la première fois la réalité
de leur choix et la réalité de leur
souhait puisque rien était imposé ils
ont pu avoir pour la première fois des
informations qui était identique pour
l'ensemble des lycéens
et ça je crois que ça a été aussi saluée
par les familles et par les lycéens
eux-mêmes lorsqu'ils avaient dans leur
entourage
d'autres personnes qui avaient utilisé
la précédente plateforme
c'est le point de départ évidemment un
enseignement et c'est important c'est
important de parler de cette phase
d'orientation en fait qui a qui s'est
tenue pendant toute cette période
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars avec un
véritable accompagnement des professeurs
principaux qui ont fait un travail
absolument formidable avec les lycéens
qui nous ont dit que le fait d'avoir des
groupes plus petit ça leur avait permis
de se mettre autour d'une table et de
parler avec les lycéens de leurs projets
d'avenir chose qu'il n'avait pas
forcément le temps de faire auparavant
et c'est une mission qui leur étaient
pas qui leur était pas confiée donc
s'inquiètent de ne pas être admis voulu
quoique il sera forcément mieux ou pas
forcément alors oui j'entends leur
inquiétude d'autant plus qu' évidemment
là encore un certain nombre de personnes
cherchent à les inquiéter en leur
racontant des choses qui sont absolument
fausses sur sur cette plateforme pour
l'instant les lucioles n'ont pas bougé
vous croisez les doigts
non je croisais les doigts je remercie
tous les professeurs qui les accompagne
tous les jours et qui avec eux ont pris
le temps d'expliquer qu'elle était
l'esprit de cette réforme et non
dernière on a tiré 65000 lycéens au sort
pour savoir si oui ou non ils pourraient
aller dans la filière de leur choix
on les a obligés à 810 1000 lycéens
comment est ce que vous pouvez les
rassurer individuellement d'abord tout
simplement que son dossier puisque ces
engagements soient examinées vraiment
individuellement alors il faut bien
comprendre que cette réforme dans sa
globalité elle a été co construite avec
les acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur
que ce soient les représentants des
personnels les représentants des
étudiants
les chefs d'établissement et tout l'été
toute la durée de cette discussion nous
avons co construit la solution pour
sortir du tirage au sort ensemble et
pour commencer à résoudre la question de
70 % d'échec en première année
tout l'été je leur ai dit est ce que sur
cette mesure là vous pensez que nous
serons en mesure de la mettre en place
parce que c'est extrêmement important de
mettre les lycéens dans une situation où
ils peuvent faire confiance à
l'enseignement supérieur tout l'été la
réponse a été oui j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller dans les universités et de voir
les gens qui sont au travail autour de
ces dossiers pour préparer les
accompagnements pour la rentrée on a
travaillé avec les recteurs et les
présidents d'université les présidents
ont indiqué partout où ils avaient
besoin de place on a financé 19 passes
supplémentaires à redon est exactement
la hausse était nécessaire tous ces
bacheliers qu'ils auront une place
quelque part à la rentrée est ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui de garantir ce
que je veux c'est ce qui les inquiète
c'est où est ce que je serai en
septembre mais si vous me permettez je
vais vous répondre en deux temps d'abord
certains bacheliers n'ont demandé que
des filières sélectives et s'ils n'ont
demandé que des filières sélectives la
chose que je peux leur garantir c'est
que la commission électorale prendra
contact avec eux s'ils n'ont aucun de
leur choix en filières sélectives et
leur fera des propositions au plus près
de leur choix ça c'est la première chose
que je peux garantir la deuxième chose
c'est que pour tous les lycéens qui ont
demandé des filières non sélective nous
avons d'ores et déjà financées
dix neuf mille places supplémentaires en
regardant très exactement où on avait
besoin de ces places et au fur et à
mesure que la procédure se déroulera
nous pourrons ouvrir encore d'autres
places la seule limite si je puis dire
c'est les murs de l'université quand
toutes les salles sont prises dans tous
les amphis sont son prix évidemment là
dans cette université là ce n'est pas
possible mais on ne s'arrête pas pour
autant
et là encore le rôle de la commission
rectorales c'est de signaler tout ce qui
est possible dans les universités
alentours ou dans d'autres philippe
rochard il ya des lycéens qui peuvent se
retrouver sans affectation en aller en
de l'année dernière l'année dernière
tirés au sort 65 mille étudiants et il
est resté au mois de septembre 89
bacheliers généraux parce qu'on n'avait
pas réussi à les joindre
donc si on a réussi à faire ça l'année
dernière avec aucune anticipation
vous comprenez bien que notre ambition
notre volonté c'est que cette année on
soit en capacité d'accueillir chaque
bachelier qui le souhaitent dans
l'enseignement supérieur alors on nous
vous écoutons attentivement madame la
ministre vous parler de l'orientation de
l'accompagnement des lycéens n'est ce
pas mais les français ils ont compris
qu'il s'agissait d'une sélection écoute
et voilà le résultat de la deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
parcours sup introduite et la sélection
à l'entrée en fac et bien les gens
répondent oui à 66% voilà c'est ce
qu'ils ont compris alors pourquoi ne pas
assumer madame vidal cette notion de
sélection à l'entrée en fac pour éviter
ce que vous avez rappelé effectivement
la sélection à l'issue de la première
année par l'échec
c'est une question de manque pas du tout
ce n'est pas une question de mots ce
n'est pas de la sélection et quand je
vous parle d'accompagnement en fait ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que
lorsqu'on a le baccalauréat et que l'on
souhaite s'engager donc ses études
supérieures il y a toujours des moyens
de réussir ce sera parfois plus long on
devra parfois prendre le temps de
s'orienter mieux on devrait être
accompagné par des professeurs mais il
n'y a pas de fatalité a échoué dans
l'enseignement supérieur je peux vous
donner un exemple moi je je j'ai
enseigné je voulais dire toute ma vie
est en tout cas tout est léger tenu à le
faire aussi en premier cycle et en
première année je me rappelle d'une
étudiante qui est arrivé avec un
baccalauréat qu'il avait préparé à des
techniques de l'analyse médicale elle
est venue me voir à la fin du cours elle
m'a dit madame je comprends pas les mots
que vous employez je comprends pas
pourtant joseph sur j'aime la biologie
j'ai fait ça jusqu'à mon bac je veux y
arriver
qu'est ce que je lui dis je lui ai dit
en fait tu es doué et tu sais faire des
choses que les autres ne savent pas
faire tu sais utiliser des pipettes tu
sais faire des examens
donc on va rentrer avec toi par les
travaux pratiques et quand on va rentrer
avec toi par les travaux pratiques
tu vas te rendre compte que finalement
tu peux accueillir avec derrière elle à
théo vous êtes appuyé sur votre
expérience personnelle peut être vous
même vous avez tellement poussé johnny
je ne suis pas un cas unique j'ai fait
ça dans une équipe pédagogique
je connais dans toutes les universités
des gens et vous la seule différence
c'est que maintenant la loi permet que
ces initiatives soit reconnu qu'elle ne
soit pas faite sous forme de bénévolat
ou sous forme de petites
expérimentations mais on va pouvoir les
général d'accord parce qu'il n'ya pas
une inquiétude légitime sur les
algorithmes qui ont une part de
l'importante dans l'orientation télé c1
est ce que vous allez faire toute la
lumière quand on connaîtra c'est la
grande question du moment a commencé et
algorithmes fonctionne dès ce qu'il ne
soit pas piégeux s'est engagé et c'est
prévu par la loi la totalité des
algorithmes seront publiés donc ça c'est
je pense même inscrit un scribe on ne
sait pas dans la loi c'est dans le
décret d'application de la loi donc les
algorithmes seront absolument connu et
là-dessus j'allais dire il n'y a pas de
sujet autant il ya une contestation des
universitaires de certains d'entre eux à
tout le moins qui refusent de trier
c'est le rehausser leurs mots mais elle
rêve qui ne veut pas jouer le jeu
alors qu'est ce que c'est un acte de
désobéissance un acte d'autorité
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ces
enseignants du supérieur qui refusent de
d'étudier les dossiers de parcours su
mais je pense que une fois encore ils
n'ont pas complètement compris quelle
était la philosophie
donc ça veut dire que j'ai pas réussi a
alors expliqué qu'elle était l'objectif
l'objectif c'est en aucun cas de dire
non mais l'objectif c'est d'accueillir
la diversité quand vous êtes en fils on
à 96 mille enseignants et
enseignants-chercheurs dans
l'enseignement supérieur y en a 400 qui
disent qu'il ne souhaite pas le faire
les autres sont en train de le faire moi
je pense que ces enseignants chercheurs
ils viendront ils viendront aussi parce
que leurs étudiants leur demanderons à
un moment et verdi
monde moi aussi je veux avoir des
travaux dirigés en plus moi aussi je
veux qu'on tienne compte du fait que
j'ai besoin d'être plus aider pourquoi
vous ne faites pas dans cette filière et
ils leur coupent d'accord là vous dites
que les lycéens pourrait au pire en une
certaine manière obtenir comme réponse
oui si à leur voeu c'est bien cela oui
pourquoi ce serait pire ce serait
content comme opportune dit on peut leur
dire oui c'est si il y à un complément
de formation mais là il ya un hic c'est
ce que disent tous les présidents
d'université avec qui vous êtes en
contact évidemment quotidiennement le
problème des moyens écouter jean
françois abalo des quel président de
l'université de nanterre il vous
interpelle madame la ministre
accompagner les publics les plus
fragiles
c'est une noble ambition comment comptez
vous aider les universités à déployer
ces dispositifs
sachant que les universités souffrent
d'un sous investissement sachant que là
le coût moyen d'un étudiant est deux
fois inférieur à celui d'un élève de
classe préparatoire
n'y at-il pas à ce point où nous nous
trouvons à penser un plan ambitieux pour
accompagner les universités et leur
permettre d'aider à la réussite du plus
grand nombre d'étudiants
ce plan ambitieux vous allez aller
réclamer mais bien sûr mais ce plan
ambitieux je comprends bien il faut le
replacer dans ce qui a déjà été fait le
budget 2010 8 des universités ses 234
millions d'euros de plus par rapport à
l'année dernière donc vous dire celle de
la sensée suffisait laissez moi juste
terminée je ne dis pas que c'est
suffisant je rappelle juste que le
gouvernement a déjà fait à cette
augmentation budgétaire de l'année 2018
le gouvernement a souhaité ajouter un
milliard d'euros spécifiquement fléchés
sur l'orientation et l'accueil en
première année d'accord donc c'est un
milliard d'euros qui sont concentrés sur
cet accueil en première année mais ceci
dit et jean françois baldé le sait très
bien les discussions ne sont pas
terminées parce que moi je veux qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout de cette réforme
vous qu'on reconnaisse l'engagement des
enseignants des enseignants chercheurs
des équipes pédagogiques
y compris des administratifs qui
accueillent ces étudiants je veux qu'on
fasse en sorte que la carrière des
enseignants-chercheurs ne soit pas
fondée uniquement sur leurs publications
scientifiques
je veux que l'accueil à l'université
soit une véritable variable prise en
compte dans ces carrières
donc nous sommes en train de discuter
sur dalle indemnitaire nous allons
discuter sur les plans de carrière nous
recevons toutes les organisations
représentatives des étudiants et des
personnels dans le courant de la semaine
nous recevrons avec le premier ministre
la conférence des présidents
d'université pour continuer à travailler
sur ses moyens c'est pas c'est pas de la
faute de ce gouvernement si ça fait 20
ans que le budget des universités est en
permanence sous-estimé donc si je
comprends bien vous avez la conduction
sous-estimé j'ai été présidente
d'université je sais ce que ça signifie
d'annoncer la création de milliers de
postes mais dans le même temps de ne pas
compenser les augmentations de salaires
ça se traduit par quoi ça se traduit par
le fait qu' on embauche personne parce
que l'argent qui arrive pour embaucher
sert à payer les salaires des gens qui
sont là pour la première fois cette
année on a ouvert des postes pour
l'accueil en premier cycle et on a mis
en face les budgets qui correspondent le
fils de la question pour cette partie un
mot sur la réussite en licence c'est un
peu votre combat la loi en tout cas fixe
tel un objectif à atteindre
on sait qu'aujourd'hui le seuil est très
très bas est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous fixé
un objectif à atteindre l'objectif à
atteindre ne sera en aucun cas un
objectif chiffré par an le l'ambition
otages à partir de quelque 5 4 % des
bacheliers dans une génération pas
encore là encore je crois qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre ce que veut faire
cette loi compris qu'est ce que vous
voulez mais alignement
allez comprendre pourquoi l'absence de
données ce type de statistiques par
année ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
les bacheliers qui entre à l'université
on leur donne pas seulement une carte
d'étudiant on les accompagne pour qu'ils
réussissent leur diplôme que ce soit en
trois ans
que ce soit en quatre ans que ce soit en
se réorientant mais en gardant les
acquis de l'année qu'ils ont déjà fait
ce qui nous importe c'est de mettre les
jeunes dans une situation de réussite et
de confiance en eux et d'arrêter de les
mettre dans une situation d'échec qui y
compris psychologiquement influent sur
la façon dont ensuite il se projette
dans l'avenir et dans la société très
dévalorisant un accueil bienveillant de
toute cette diversité un accueil très
inclusif et c'est pour ça qu
effectivement il faut des moyens et
c'est pour ça que tout ne sera pas
parfait dès la première année et c'est
pour ça qu'il faudra qu'il va carthage
d'expérience ou de vendée dont ça ne ça
ne peut pas se traduire par un chiffre
c'est parce qu'on a d'être non par des
étudiants on part de tellement bas on
espère que ça le plus vite possible
est ce que votre calme que vous affichez
encore ce soir est un atout dans
l'épreuve de force que vous traversez
écoutez je sais c'est mon tempérament je
vois là je ne sais pas si je suis pas
particulièrement calme particulièrement
énervé par contre c'est à dire moi je ne
pourrais jamais m'empêcher je pense
d'être professeur donc
j'explique une fois deux fois trois fois
c'est ça la pédagogie c'est la
répétition et bien vous allez pouvoir
encore vous expliquer avec la troisième
question maintenant de l'épreuve de
vérité que va vous poser paulo bria
[Musique]
vidal les classements internationaux
sont rarement flatteur alors est ce que
l'université française peut encore tenir
son rang face à la concurrence mondiale
a alors sur la question des classements
c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
intéressant et plus récemment elle a
trois principaux
mais poussés et shanghaï mais il faut
toujours comprendre d'où viennent les
choses alors là encore juste en quelques
mots le classement de shanghai il a été
créé parce que le gouvernement chinois
voulait investir massivement dans
quelques-unes de ces universités et a
demandé à une de ces universités
d'imaginer un classement qui lui
permettrait de voir à partir de quand
son investissement serait visible sur
des critères internationaux comme
l'obtention des prix nobel
l'attraction de prix nobel et un certain
nombre de critères qui ont été
considérées parlera par la colla on va
dire l'ensemble des pays comme les
critères les seuls critères d'évaluation
d'université se sont loin d'être les
seuls donc c'est important d'être
présent dans shanghai mais je pense
qu'il faut donner à shanghai la place
qui l'intéressent asseman vous juger la
créativité l'attractivité des
universités françaises
elle se juge à la capacité qu'ont les
universités d'attirer des étudiants
internationaux et d'attirer des
chercheurs de haut niveau là et ça pour
le moment
les choses vont plutôt bien puisque nous
avons attirer plus d'étudiants
internationaux que les précédentes
années et que nous sommes tout à fait en
capacité d'attirer des jeunes talents
puisque dans les procédures de
recrutement national sur les concours de
la fonction publique
que ce soit les enseignants chercheurs
ou les chercheurs on a à peu près 30% de
recrutement internationaux donc la
france reste un pays attractif par son
enseignement supérieur et sa recherche
le prix nobel d'économie jean tirole
critiqué récemment le fonctionnement des
universités et vous serez d'accord avec
lui quand il réclame plus d'ambition
pour nos universités en france il
déclarait ceci jean tirole il ya
quelques jours dans les échos il a
évidemment pour pour la sélection il dit
que l'université a déboulé au pied face
aux grandes écoles hautement sélective
mieux doté et agile grâce à une
gouvernance plus souple est ce qu'il dit
vrai le prix nobel d'économie
alors là encore c'est intéressant quand
on lit tout son arc tools la totalité de
son interview il ya des points avec
lesquels je suis d'accord d'autres avec
lesquels je ne suis pas d'accord
il y en a un que nous partageons
absolument c'est l'ambition nécessaire
pour l'université française
d'accord je vais vous donner un autre
point de vue cette fois dans le figaro
c'était il ya quelques jours vendredi je
crois les céistes libéral gaspard koenig
qui rallongerait lycée il ya eu des
prises de position il
il a dit avoir fui l'université mais il
dit ceci à propos de l'élite entre
guillemets l'élite il parle des parents
peut être informés ou des couches
sociales supérieures l'élite fait tout
pour éviter ce purgatoire il parle de
l'université à ses rejetons s'était dit
en voie s'est élevé ses enfants en prépa
à l'étranger dans des établissements
privés alors qu'est ce que vous dites là
vous serez pas d'accord du tout sur
toute la ligne
non non je ne sont pas une part de
vérité malgré tout bien qu'on puisse que
deux corées alors pour moi
l'université reste un lieu qui est tout
à fait particulier dans l'enseignement
supérieur
c'est le lieu où à la fois se construit
la connaissance puisqu'il y aller
laboratoires de recherche qui sont en
général des laboratoires mixtes mais qui
peuvent être des laboratoires purement
universitaire et c'est les gens qui
construisent la connaissance qui la
transmettent c'est à dire que au delà de
la connaissance transmises on transmet
la façon dont on crée de la connaissance
et ça c'est unique donc évidemment que
les universités françaises de ce point
de vue là comme l'ensemble des
universités garde cette spécificité
cette particularité
après je dirais pas que tout est rose
dans les universités françaises mais je
dis que voilà ce sont les lieux où les
choses fonctionnent comme ça où il est
aussi important d'apprendre à apprendre
que d'apprendre les choses en tant que
tel et où surtout on explique comment on
ce moment au questionne les choses
acquises pour obtenir de la connaissance
nouvelle pour répondre à gaspard koenig
vous appelez ces gens là cette élite
dans laquelle je crois il s'inclut à
faire un espèce d'actes patriotique et
de dire inscrivez vos enfants à
l'université après tout fait confiance
aussi au système éducatif à la française
hausse je pense que les gens font aller
on va inscrire vos enfants dans des
prépas à l'étranger à l'as tu es ici et
là encore je crois que il faut faire il
faut faire attention à ne pas
généraliser la pratique de quelques-uns
s'il ya des gens qui souhaitent que
leurs enfants aillent faire leurs études
ou le début de leurs études à l'étranger
bart eeckhout et voilà qu'il le fasse
c'est pas un sujet le sujet c'est que
l'état français
garantie à tous les enfants de la nation
une éducation de l'enseignement
supérieur de qualité et c'est ça
vraiment pour moi le fond du sujet et
c'est pas seulement une carte d'étudiant
c'est aussi la capacité à réussir alors
il ya aussi la capacité à se payer des
études vous l'avez rappelé effectivement
beaucoup d'étudiants n'ont pas pris le
mouvement en marche ces dernières
semaines parce qu'ils expliquent bas on
ne peut pas rater notre année on a un
job parfois deux jobs on n'a pas de boer
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez annoncer
promettent je ne sais pas est ce que
c'est un nouveau combat aussi pour
lutter contre une forme de paupérisation
des étudiants dans notre pays ça se
traduit notamment par le fait qu'ils se
soignent mal d'abord effectivement pour
moi la réussite ça inclut aussi la
qualité de la vie des étudiants donc
c'est pour ça qu'avec le premier
ministre la première chose qu'on nous
avons souhaité faire c'est faire en
sorte que dès cette année la rentrée
2010 vide coûtera 100 millions d'euros
deux mois aux étudiants et à leurs
familles que la rentrée 2010 est parce
que nous avons supprimé les cotisations
spécifiques aux régimes de sécurité
sociale étudiant nous allons mettre en
place dans les établissements des
centres de santé nous travaillons à ce
que justement le
la psychologie de l'étudiant son stress
son mal-être puissent être mieux pris en
compte et c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est tout l'intérêt de
dire à un étudiant tu as réussi trois
unités d'enseignement même si l'année en
compte dix cas l'importance tu en as
réussi trois parce que c'était ça ton
défi plutôt que de lui dire battant a
raté sept et donc tu as raté vous voyez
tout ça c'est aussi une façon de
remettre l'étudiant au coeur du système
les étudiants qui travaillent pour payer
leurs études
bien sûr que je les comprends tout à
fait je vois même tout à fait ce qu'ils
sont en train de vivre
c'est très important évidemment pour eux
que leurs diplômes garde de la valeur
nous travaillons aussi à faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus d'emplois étudiants
dans les universités parce que moi je
suis convaincu que il y a beaucoup plus
d'intérêt pour un étudiant à permettre
une ouverture d'un biotech universitaire
le week end que d'être obligé d'aller
travailler dans le secteur
j'ai une question je vais utiliser le
mot sélection madame la ministre
à quoi devez-vous votre sélection par
emmanuel macron pour entrer dans le
gouvernement
je sais pas si j'ai été sélectionnée
d'une forme ou d'une autre
voilà c'est vous voyez tout de suite les
choses sont différentes et on préfère
toujours être choisir qu être
sélectionné on avait l'occasion de
d'un déjeuner ensemble lorsqu'il était
ministre et que j'étais présidente
d'université
il avait souhaité rencontrer des
présidents d'université qui avait décidé
de prendre en main leur établissement de
les faire à la fois la l'emblème de mon
université c'est est ancré dans son des
territoires ouverte à l'international
c'est vraiment ce qu'on avait ce qu'on
avait dans l'ensemble dit sophia
antipolis et donc il voulait rencontrer
des présidents d'universités selon le
mot qui notamment avait été
sélectionneur les programmes
d'initiative d'excellence là où on les
attendait pas forcément simplement parce
que il y avait peut-être une forme
d'originalité dans notre projet qui a
été reconnue par le gérer au nom après
lui la présidence macro ce soit nous
sommes un énorme retour donc à créer un
très beau souvenir pour moi en tout cas
un très bon souvenir et et un an après
ce qui a été fait par le président ça
vous semble satisfaisant le maquereau
nisme c'est quelque chose qui vous
convainc toujours je crois que le
formidable espoir qui a été qui a été
porté tout au long de la campagne
et puis cette façon de dire que l'avenir
ce sera aussi ce que nous en ferons tous
ensemble et que c'est très important de
de garder cet optimisme de d'essayer
toujours de voir le verre à moitié plein
plutôt que verre à moitié vide de se
rendre compte que évidemment l'état est
là pour nous protéger mais on peut aussi
se demander tous les jours qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour que notre pays
aille mieux
tout ça moi je le ressens toujours
intacte dans la volonté du président de
faire avancer la france et l'europe et
au sans doublure devront aussi et au
sein du gouvernement aussi bien sûr je
crois qu on est tous dans cette dans
cette dynamique
voilà je sais c'est un engagement que
personnel extrêmement fort ce n'est pas
notre profession d'être ministre ce
n'était pas notre vocation de devenir
ministre
nous avons tous choisi de donner une
part de notre vie à notre pays
en exerçant cette mission je crois qu'on
est nombreux à partager ce sentiment
un mot peut-être de la rencontre entre
emmanuel macron et donald trump ou aux
etats-unis le président va atterrir
d'ici une petite heure au aux états unis
on se souvient de l'appel qu'il avait
lancé quand donald trump a quitté
l'accord de paris il a dit aux
chercheurs installés aux etats-unis qui
travaillent sur les questions
climatiques
venez la france peut être une terre
refuge on est prêt à vous accueillir
est ce que vous savez aujourd'hui
combien ont répondu à cet appel combien
ou ont toqué à la porte
bon bien sûr le premier appel il ya eu à
peu près 450 dossiers déposés pas
uniquement des états unis mais une
grosse moitié venant des états unis
une première vague de 18 sélectionnés
une deuxième vague en ce moment de 14
sélectionnés et l'allemagne nous
accompagne aussi donc c'est un mouvement
qui s'enclenche et la paradoxale on à
emmanuel macron qu'il va faire ami ami
avec d'un autre homme qui célèbre les
amériques et aujourd'hui on a des
réfugiés intellectuelle des chercheurs
pour entraver leur pays qui viennent
trouver refuge en francs par définition
la recherche c'est quelque chose
d'international alors quand on est
empêché dans son pays c'est important de
savoir qu'on peut continuer dans
d'autres pays merci beaucoup madame la
ministre avec nous dans cette période
toujours aussi agité mais bon on a suivi
avec vous à les derniers événements et
notamment on a pu faire au cours de
cette émission le point sur ce mouvement
étudiant qui ne l'est pas tout à fait si
l'on vous écoute en tous les cas dans
ces manifestations de blocages merci à
vous deux merci à tous a très vite merci
dans ce cas
[Musique]